mm-hmm you made your bed now you have to
lie in there mm-hmm like it's just a
mockery to the whole thing and then to
be trying to drag other women into your
whatever speech that was leave us out of
it we're good ma'am you are the problem
you set back women right i mean it's
just her victim complex to me is just
she's dangerous she is she's so
dangerous yeah because even though after
the conclusion she if i was in her place
i would turn off the wi-fi like for a
month or a year you know and turn off my
account and be like
no goodbye world bye-bye
you know but no she has like the gut to
post something like that and just keep
going and that's i call it the audacity
yeah exactly i think she sounds very
narcissis narcissist
she is she is like the definition of
being a narcissist it's almost like
maybe in the time span of their
relationship
one incident happened and she has
completely dramatized that incident and
replayed it in her mind and it's just
just crazy i guess she loved the
attention though because this whole
thing made her even a bigger public
figure yeah she literally loved the
attention she wants she wanted it to
carry on and on and on so she can
actually come out do a bit of over drama
over reactions and then get attention
from people so everybody everybody knew
who johnny depp was everybody loved
johnny depp captain jack sparrow
everything everybody knew him and
they're like who's amber
[Laughter]
now that this case has come out
everyone's like
oh amber this amber that looking up
videos and it's just it's just like a
revenue for her and it's just feeding
into her her ego for lack of better
words for all of this and i just
it's so
amazing how some people can
make up a lie
and we hear it and it's like you got
stung by a bee
your dog died and you pooped in the bed
how what what does that what does that
have to do with anything
and it's like the way she's telling it
yeah she was like
when she was talking about uh johnny
grabbed my hair and
he was and it's just like ma'am it was
just like if you come on
did you go through it or not yes you may
be traumatized but you you're pausing as
if you're making it up and the way
you're talking about it i've seen so
many videos people are like oh he
slapped me and then i turned around and
people reenacting it and i'm like if you
look at me it doesn't make sense it
doesn't make sense it's like
they're facing the opposite way and
she's like johnny why did you slap me
and it's just like it's just
people's minds are just
just
a whole world in itself to be able to
make up a lie keep going with it and
believe it and you're like everybody
should believe it because i believe it
have you ever met one of those people in
real life i'm thinking of a specific man
right i'm thinking of a dude who is like
this and
no no not like that crazy like he was
saying someone beat him but just like
have you ever met like a pathological
liar and you're like how do you lie that
fast no i haven't really never even you
yeah
this girl she would one day her dad was
in the hospital and then her mum was in
the hospital and then this person had
this and this person had that and the
first couple of times you're like oh my
god i'm so concerned and then the next
couple of times you're like jesus christ
like you when it rains it literally
pours and you're getting soaked what is
going on with you
the um and it's crazy because amber
heard reportedly plans to appeal against
johnny depp defamation verdict
the actor amber hurd is reported to be
planning an appeal after losing
a defamation trial against her former
husband johnny depp over allegations of
sexual abuse
no sorry domestic not sexual domestic
abuse jurors in a virginia court ruled
in favor of death um on three counts
awarding the pirates of the caribbean
actor 15 million which was later
reduced by the judge to 10.35 million
do you feel like that was a fair
punishment i think she should have
gotten more yeah like is ten point
whatever even going to cover his lawyers
or like is it i'm confused i don't know
because this case went on for a long
time really 15 million it was like 10
million for like his and uh yeah five
minutes reward and five million for the
punitive something yeah
i i think they should sue the the
company that published the op-ed too i
think that was really irresponsible as a
journalist
so i work in media i wouldn't like
that's so irresponsible because that's a
that's a big thing to be like
yes if it's some small person be like
okay we can
uh publish this but it's johnny depp and
that
that article took him off of the pirates
of the caribbean because of that and
this is like
do you realize how
like big that is for that article to
then get to the um production company of
pirates of the caribbean to take him
take him
johnny depp who
in my opinion made pirates of the
caribbean take him out of it to where
he's not in it anymore that's huge so i
think however much they were going to
pay him in that production company for
the movie for the time for everything
post uh production everything i think
she should have to pay i think she
should go to jail
yeah i think she should go to jail
because you're taking that man's lively
like i think that's what she did was
meaner
that like
if someone told me okay you could either
spend two years in jail and come out or
you for the next decade of your life you
can't do media you can't do any of the
[ __ ] that you love i would pick two
years in jail yeah other than like
because she took away the one thing that
he loves doing like that gives him life
but now he's gonna have way more jobs
you know because now he got his
repetition a reputation back the thing
is i think amber is really dumb because
she will never get a job as an actor i
don't think so
you know she she didn't have many jobs
exactly but i think in the future like
she would not even be you know allowed
in the in the productions or even in tv
you know
and you know yeah
to be honest yeah i think she actually
helped him like she i mean she didn't
have any he didn't need any help of
course because he's a great actor and he
always had you know fame he'll never get
that series back i know i know i'm not
saying that i'm saying amber i think
she's really dumb she really damaged her
career there was like just like this
this much that is none like it's not
existing
you know damage is done isn't it and in
regards to that report that you guys
were mentioning before speaking to the
mic the reporter sorry you were
mentioning before
we live in a society where you can
literally just post an apology like what
repercussion is she actually gonna have
she could just oh yeah i apologize like
apologies seem to go far it's just
ridiculous yeah just not enough and yeah
he might be able to get contracts back
but the damage has been done since when
did they divorce in 2016.
when did they divorce i think it was
2016.
i thought it was 2017.
i think the op-ed maybe was in 2016. i
don't i don't know exactly that's five
in this case
yeah it says it says here 2016 divorce
yeah i think this case what
five years and even
with the trial like it's so evasive some
of the details that you
heard about their relationship so it's i
don't know i don't know how easy it will
be for him to
build his reputation back up because
five years is such a long time to be
defamed like that i'm not saying that he
won't but it's not going to be easy it's
not
well and um
like now he had to bring all this
personal stuff
out into the light that i'm sure he
didn't want of course he doesn't want to
know he just want the world to know that
his wife his ex-wife was beating him
yeah like guys that's i mean that can be
embarrassing for guys it's really sad
but i've talked to guys about this no no
guy wants the world to know that their
girl beating is beating them up yeah
you know what's in you know what's an
interesting stat that i just found out
the other other day this was on my story
um the majority of domestic violence
cases
both parties are abusing each other so
it's not just like one-sided and the
majority like they're both abusing each
other
and um when it is one-sided 70 of the
time it's women abuse hitting the men
and then and the men not hitting them
back so the majority of domestic abuse
cases are actually that are that are
one-sided where they're not both doing
it are actually like the women hitting
the men
yeah i i think there is more emotional
damage when a man does to a woman and
then a woman reacts probably more
physically physical
to react over emotional because i heard
a lot of stories a lot of a lot of women
and they you know we are more emotional
and men are more rational
and i think men are more aware as well
if they get emotional and physical they
will get in a lot of trouble so it's
more smart to emotional damage a woman
than actually physical because there is
no marks there is no wounds that you can
see
you know physical in a way
so that's way more smart and there's a
lot of narcissist people out there as a
man and as a woman so men that's not
true that's a very small percentage of
the population as narcissists what do
you mean it's it's it's comparing women
to men or no no just in general in
general like if you survey a like
like if you study 100 people like that's
not true good you just write
that's good
yeah there's a teacher yeah maybe you
like them i don't know
but
i met one you know
i'm now i'm like